hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar utilizing the gitco cts rotia
system
a versatile clothes manufacturing system
for cell and gene therapy development
i am jaclyn and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
and i welcome all of you to this event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by latin
and brought to you by github by thermal
fusion scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
as we are addressing the asia pacific
region we have invited our audience to
type questions
in english mandarin korean or japanese
our panelists will answer as many
questions as possible at the end of the
presentation
i would now like to welcome our three
speakers
dr prem kuma cell and gene therapy
regional field application
scientist at thermo fisher scientific
emily bentz process development engineer
at biosite and our first speaker eric
debosky
biomedical engineering master's student
at tel poly san luis obispo
premier will now introduce the wrote
here and its various applications for
closed processing of cell and gene
therapies
thank you so much and i would like to
welcome you all for this webinar
now let's look at some of the main
issues in cell therapy manufacturing
so you can see on the left um a typical
autologous t-cell therapy workflow
as you may already know it is a very
complex and labor-intensive process
which requires many open manipulations
making it prone to errors and
contamination
in addition how to synchronize different
instruments and processes
making the workflow trackable and
compliant with regulatory requirement
which is another layer of complexity so
based on these issues
we understand customers are looking for
three main solutions
closed system to close the process
modular system to remain flexible
and automation to reduce labor and human
errors
hey so this is rather an important slide
i would like to spend some time
explaining the benefits of closed
automated autologous car key options
um compared to that of a manual
processing so you can see that option
one
is the manual process um you need a
large and expensive facility with
dedicated class b processing areas
um so it is labor intensive and it's
prone to contamination
and option two is the closed automated
system with integrated incubation
um we can do parallel processing in
class c processing area
with minimal labor but the processing
instrument is poorly utilized
this is mainly because um the incubation
process
is integrated into the closed automated
system to explain in simple terms
within a typical party process we would
expect
at least 7 to 14 days of incubation
during which the entire instrument
is tied up to one patient sample which
means if you want to process
2000 patients per year for a seven day
incubation period
you would require at least 80
instruments which is a very expensive
things to set up on the other hand
option three
is the closed automation system using
modular instruments
with centralized incubation in
single-use vessels
um such as static cell culture bags or
g-racks or rocker bioreactors
this is more of an appropriate and a
cost-effective strategy
meaning instead of having all the
processes such as cell separation
incubation formulation integrated into a
single instrument
you would have modular instruments to
carry out each unit operation of the
workflow
and this is what thermo fisher is
currently providing
okay so this is our vision for our cell
therapy manufacturing workflow
um we provide best-in-class close
modular and automated instruments
in combination with superior reagents
protocols and analytical solutions
we are taking a modular approach in
closed automated cell therapy
manufacturing
with the centralized incubation the
graph below depicts our approach for an
end-to-end t-cell therapy manufacturing
platform
so starting from rotia which i'll be
talking in detail later
pbmcs are isolated and directly
transferred into our cts dynamic system
for magnetic t cell isolation with our
cd3 cd28 dynamics
once the d cells are isolated they can
be transferred using the g3 lab
controller
into an incubation system of choice uh
here we have shown our high performance
bioreactor
after the t cells are expanded the
entire process just goes through the
reverse sequence
the expanded cells are transferred back
into the cts dynamic
to remove the residual dynamics and the
cell suspension is
washed and formulated for prior
preservation using roti again
so while we can physically integrate
these instruments we are also enabling
digital integration platforms
and our goal is to provide direct
connection to delta v platform
to support full automation overall um we
can promise a full integrated workflow
with a scalable and robust uh
manufacturing performance
again shown here is the schematic of a
gene modified t cell therapy workflow
and we have products that support every
step of the workflow
so for selection of t cells we have our
cts dynamics and dynamic magnet for
large scale t-cell isolation
and for viral based gene modifications
we have variety of
tools such as the cts lvmax and have a
new aav max prototype
and for non-viral based methods we
provide cth
true cut class 9 protein and talons
which can be delivered to cells with our
new large scale cts electroporation
system which is scheduled to launch
this year and after gene modification
for t
cell expansion we have variety of crp
media choices
such as our cts optimizer specifically
designed for autologous t-cells
expansion and our cts optimizer pro
for allergenic t-cell expansion and
finally our cts aim five media for
expanding
variety of other immune cells and now i
would like to introduce our recently
launched closed and automated solution
called cts rotia
for 17 therapy of into being processed
so you can see that from starting
uh from the pbmc isolation from a
leukopak and throughout the process
there are multiple steps of subwash
concentrate media buffer exchange
and cell separation as well so rotia can
basically do it all
but most importantly in a modular way
and centralized incubation
okay so rotia is a compact closed
automated cell processing system
designed specifically for self-driving
manufacturing and i would like to
highlight four key benefits here
so with proprietary counter flow
centrifugation technology
it allows customers to perform flexible
operations such as cell separation based
on size
wash concentrate buffer exchange and
formulate
the unique chamber design allows very
low output volume of 5 mils
the superior cell recovery and viability
is typically more than 95
so no other product in the market i can
deliver or achieve a low output volume
of 5 ml
which is very critical to obtain high
cell density concentration as an output
and this is required for operations such
as electroporation
and formulation and further at the most
important
point the opc ua interface supports 21
cfr part 11 compliance
we will also provide extensive
regulatory support documentation for the
instrument and the single use case
okay now let's look at the closer look
of the whole system
um the compact system allows easy
integration into your process it's only
20 kgs
the close single use kit is sterilized
by gamma radiation
and has flexible input and output ports
which allow faster multi-process
integration we have two types of kits um
the standard kit with a flow rate of
five to 110 ml per minute and for
processing larger volumes we have
a high flow kit um with the flow rates
to 30 to 160 mils
per minute and on the software itself
with the unique cell cam technology
you can visualize yourself while you're
processing it and this is the unique
feature of rotia
which you cannot see in other
competitive products in the market
and you can adjust the g-force in the
flow rate settings during the process
development
um so the user-programmable gui allows
you to easily create your own protocols
but however we provide a preset um
protocols for
different applications
now let's look at how the counter flow
certification works so you can see here
there are two forces
g-force in the flow rate acting in
opposite direction
so first cells enter the chamber through
a narrow tube at a certain flow rate
shown in red arrow and the high fluid
entry velocity ensures
that the cells exit the tip of the
chamber at the same time the chamber
spins at the opposite
uh g-force to prevent cells from exiting
the chamber
so when the flow rate and the g-force
are balanced um a fluidized set of cells
are formed in the chamber
and and it's maintained in the chamber
so you can see that when in a normal
manual centrifugation what you
form is a pellet um here the cells are
happily floating in the in the
buffer so at this stage you can perform
media exchange
cell wash cell separation by size and
also concentrate on power
and due to the due to the conical shape
design of the chamber
and the narrowing of the chamber um
which increases the fluid velocity and
forces
some of the smaller cells out through
the top of the chamber first
um so this process is called elutration
and how you do this is basically you
reduce the g-force
and increase the flow rate to separate
the the smaller cells from the largest
cell
um and um instead of eliminating of just
the smaller cells you could also choose
to deplete unwanted smaller cells um for
example
when you're loading a loophole back um
tiny platelets and
plasma immediately leave the chamber
while you're loading it
and the pbmcs are retained in the
chamber you can achieve
platelet depletion simply from sample
loading again and in fact roti is able
to deplete debris and small size dead
cells
which gives this consistent achievement
of high survival
and as i mentioned earlier the g-force
and the flow rate settings can be
adjusted to separate smaller cells um
again the g-force is lowered allowing
the smaller cells to leave the chamber
and collected in an intermediate back um
so this is an example
of how we perform monocyte and
lymphocyte separation so you can see the
lymphocytes are shown as the yellow
beads which are six to seven microns
while the monocytes are shown as the
blue beat which is an average of around
10 microns
so to achieve higher purity of larger
cells uh or the monocytes
we can choose to optimize the volume of
electricity buffer uh to collect the
small
cells to the lymphocytes so next you can
concentrate and harvest the monocytes
into a separate bag
further you can bring back the
illuterated lymphocytes
into the chamber for volume reduction
and harvesting separately
so in line with this we have evaluated
rhodia for processing
different cell types such as tbmc t
cells mses
x293 cells ipsc steroids and there are
limitless opportunities to perform
variety of applications such as cell
isolation
small to medium scale processing prior
preserved cell
wash media exchange formulation for
product preservation
rbc lysis or depletion lv or aav
clarification and the list
keeps growing so to put in simple terms
um it's a
single instrument a single kit but
multiple applications
and and more importantly it's a modular
system so once one process is completed
the system is basically free for the
next step
in this study here um a single donor
deco pack was split into two and we
wanted to compare the efficiency of ppmc
isolation using manual
cycle protocol and the closed automated
rotia separation
with no phycology involved so you can
see that
we can also do uh the key takeaway point
here is the rotate and isolate pvmcs in
a closed process
but in less than 30 minutes with
equivalent performance to fight call
um there's a common question in the
field that whether rbc lysis
um process impacts the viability of the
pbmcs
and quality of the cell composition um
so you can clearly see from the data
here that
rbc lysis process in rotia does not have
any impact on the cell population
um the recovery and the viability being
high
and we also have protocols now to
process other samples such as the whole
blood
and buffy code um using um heterostats
or any obesity device as well
next after pbmc isolation um
using rbc lysis and rhodia we could
separate the lymphocytes and monocyte
fraction by just optimizing the g-force
and flow rate settings again
so in this demo we took a fresh look-up
back sample carried out an in-chamber
lysis followed by monocytes and
lymphocyte separation
so before rbc lysis the fresh lipopak
sample had total of three billion
uh white blood cells as an input with 22
monocytes and 55
lymphocytes um after we did the rbc
lysis the total pbmc's uh by more than
90
and we managed to separate um more than
67 percent of the monocyte fraction
in the monocyte harvest bag um on a
separate note the lymphocyte fraction
has more than 80 enrichment but the data
is not shown here
so depending on the starting donor pbmc
composition
the separation efficiency will be varied
but uh we can adjust the geforce on the
flow rate settings
um in the model feature to entirely
optimize
and maximize the enrichment of each of
the cell population
and again here are some data showcasing
rotis capability um
as i mentioned we can get more than 95 t
cell recovery and viability after
washing concentrate
and this holds for other cell types as
well and you can see that the maximum
number of t cells accumulated in the
chamber
and the counter flow centrifugation
chamber volume 10 ml
and can hold up to 5 billion t cells or
3 billion
adult stem cells but depending on the
cell size and the density of the media
although the chamber size is only 10 ml
a continuous processing can be performed
using rotia
with multiple discharges if you have
more than 5 billion cells to process
and like i mentioned the output volume
can be as low as five mils without
compromising the recovery and the
viability
um this is a great feature again for uh
preparing for your earth operation or
formulation
um and at last the t cell quality and
ratio is also not
affected um by the root here process
um so similar to the t cells we have
washed and concentrated freshly expanded
ntsl
using our new proprietary feeder free nk
expansion prototype media
on the left you can see around 650
million nk cells that
formed in the chamber um on the right
and you can see that the pre and post
rotary viability did not shift
uh maintained around 97 percent and the
total cell recovery was around 84
um and the purity of the nps cells
measured by the cd56 marker
um shows a similar range for pre and
phosphorus here
so it's kind of clearly evident that um
highly sensitive cells like t cells and
nk cells
the rotia is very gentle and retains the
population as well
and uh rotier process is flexible and
can fit into the msc
manufacturing workflow as well um either
if you are a 2d monolayer
or 3d microcarrier-based suspension
culture so
starting from a working cell bank rotate
can be used to talk cryo-preserved mses
wash media exchange with fresh media and
transfer into a cell factory or
bioreactor
directly for expansion so for each step
in the process rotia can be used for
volume reduction
wash concentrates the harvest itself
either for further profiling or for
formulation
of cryopreservation uh but for
microcarrier cultures we recommend
harvesting
a upstream of protea to separate the
cells from the microkeras
and yeah you can see here that rotate
can be used for processing small to
medium
to large scale cultures up to 20 liters
but depending on the robustness of the
cell
um you can use rotia to process uh
cells by directly harvesting from
single-use
expansion systems so for small scale
process optimization we process cultures
less than 500 mils you can connect the
syringes for easier evaluation of cell
phones
and we can also see that protein can be
connected directly to cell factories or
bioreactors
or you can transfer the cell suspension
to a larger bag and you can process
so it's a very flexible instrument you
can connect both upstream and downstream
systems
okay um here we carried out an
experiment for washing uh cryopreserved
patient derived mscs
um with two different buffers on the
left you can see hundred million cells
in the chamber
and post-survival deals around 90 and on
the right you can see rotier performance
in terms of recovery and viability
with the one or two wash steps so
compared to the manual centrifugation of
only 50
recovery uh rokia managed to achieve an
average of 75
recovery and also it is more than 80
cell biopsy
um and the key point that i would like
to highlight here is rotia can be used
to wash away impurities such as residual
proteins growth factors chemicals
from your spent media um so in the table
below
with one time dilution of cells and one
time wash
we could remove more than 200 fold of
residual psa
and with the one time dilution of cells
and two times wash
uh we showed that we can deplete more
than 3
600 fold washout efficiency
okay so similar to the t cell and msc
application
roti is again flexible to incorporate
for viral vector manufacturing as well
so here in this experiment uh we did for
lv clarification of suspension
uh viral production cells on the left
again you can see around 300 million
ppcs in the chamber
forming a nice fluidized bed and the
lentivirus super containing supernatant
is collected in a bag for further
concentration and purification
so we managed to achieve 100 um
separation of excel from the supernatant
and the titration flow data on the right
um you can see that
comparable or slightly better
transaction efficiency
than the manual centrifugation method
okay so moving further this is another
example to show radius capability
in processing uh spheroids or organoids
or aggregates and gentle fluidized bed
without destructing their morphology um
as you can see that the ipsc steroids
are around 440 to 200 microns
in size um that are captured in the
chamber while the smaller polymers on 20
microns are washed away from the chamber
um because of the counter flow
simplification technology
um and on the right um we carried out
different g-force and flow rate settings
to optimize the conditions
for high cell recovery and viability um
so you can see that 350 g's and 40 mils
per minute
which achieves more than 86 recovery
with the
morphology being healthy and intact
okay i'm talking about ipsc ferroids uh
we recently launched our stem scale pse
suspension medium
which is a scalable easy to use medium
that supports robust expansion of fluid
potential stem cells in suspension
delivering five to ten fold expansion
for passage
and the medium um uses a steroid
self-assembly method to promote
uh psc growth and does not require the
use of micro carriers
beyond expansion capability the workflow
of change medium
and passat cells is fairly
straightforward and therefore aminable
to multiple culture formats and
automation
the stem scale medium promotes
consistent product formation and
expansion capability
across multiple lines and maintain
student potency across multiple passages
now back to the crux of this webinar our
collaborators from fireside
will share more about the experience
using rotia for uh ipsc storage
processing
over to you
thank you prem for providing insights on
the various applications of rotia
i would now like to invite emily from
viasight and eric to share more about
their work around the use of rotia for
processing
pluripotent stem cells
and so vaisay is a regenerative medicine
company developing stem cell-derived
cell therapies that hold the promise of
a functional cure for patients with type
1 diabetes
our cell therapy is a combination
product and so it's comprised of
stem cell derived insulin producing
cells encapsulated
in a immunoprotective device and so
after implant the device becomes
vascularized
to allow for nutrient and small molecule
transfer across the membrane
and so our insulin-producing cells can
then respond to blood glucose levels
as you can see by the graph here we have
performed pre-clinical
studies that show successful control of
blood glucose levels
the x-axis is time in days and the
y-axis
is showing blood glucose levels the
green line
is a non-diabetic mouse and so you can
see stable
levels and then the blue line is a
diabetic mouse where you can see
extremely large fluctuations
however after implant
and over time as our cells mature in
vivo
they begin to respond to glucose levels
and can effectively
control them similar to that observed in
the
non-diabetic mouse and so the overall
goal is
to provide long-term insulin
independency to
diabetic patients
and so our production process is occurs
over about 30 days initially we saw
human embryonic stem cells
and expand those in flasks and cell
stacks over a period of
15 days and to generate enough cell
products to then
aggregate and perform a directed
differentiation down the pancreatic
progenitor
lineage upon the final day of
differentiation
our pancreatic endoderm cells or pecca1
are frozen down
for long-term storage and then upon need
they are thawed
and seeded into one of our device
configurations
where that device is then implanted into
our patients
worldwide there is an increasing
incidence of type 1 diabetes
so to support the millions of diabetic
patients we would require a commercial
scale production of our cell
manufacturing process
and so to meet this demand one option
would be to scale out our process
scaling out involves multiplying the
number of batches and
so in our case that would lead to
hundreds of roller bottles
and as you can assume that becomes
unrealistic very quickly as this leads
to high septic risk
a large production footprint and higher
costs
therefore it's important to develop a
scale up model
where we increase watch size to support
large scale
production
so scaling up a cell therapy requires
multiple considerations
a few of them being process
comparability so ensuring that
across batches and across scales
you're producing the same product you're
maintaining
product integrity additionally
it's important to establish a great
relationship with
your vendors and even consider multiple
vendors for
various consumables and reagents
and then additionally being aware of the
facility capacity needs
and whether you perform your production
process
in-house or in collaboration with a cmo
however the focus of today's
presentation is really
identifying scale up technologies that
meet the process requirements
so for our process we have decided to
transition to suspension by reactor
systems because they're closed
controlled and scalable which allows for
a robust
commercial production process and so in
conjunction with the bioreactor we
require
a cell separation system to perform
closed media exchanges and harvesting
processes
which leads us to the rotia and so eric
will be discussing how we've
incorporated the rotia system
as a suitable technology that meets our
needs
thanks emily so first some details on
the aggregates and the drug substance
that we are using
uh that we do that we're processing with
the rotia
uh fine site drug cell drug substance or
pec 01 consists of pancreatic progenitor
aggregates
these aggregates are pretty dense
they're comprised of multiple cell
populations at different phases
of differentiation there's also
extracellular matrix
in each aggregate usually we see
aggregates between 200 and 400 microns
in diameter
the aggregates typically grow in size as
we move along the differentiation
process
so like emily mentioned we want to use
the rotea system
as part of our aggregate production
process
and the rotate system is good for this
application because it addresses several
of
our requirements for aggregate
processing specifically it allows us to
accomplish media exchange passage and
harvest of
aggregates and cells while maintaining a
closed environment
it's also an efficient processing regime
that the entire process should take
less than an hour in total there's no
effect
to aggregate viability morphology or
characterization after processing
protea is also a gentle processor and
its single use
allows us to maintain a closed
environment and minimize aseptic risk it
also allows the isolation of a specific
cell population so we can separate the
aggregates
from non-aggregates and also from any
dead or single cells that we don't want
in our final harvest
population and then finally as emily
mentioned it is a scalable technology
meaning that as we scale up our
production process the rotea will be
able to be scaled with
us
so a brief overview of the pec 01 scale
up development workflow
and where the rotata fits into that
workflow
to start our production process we
expand uh
human embryonic stem cells from thaw
into 2d interior culture on flasks
move from flask to cell stacks and then
we aggregate
our cells in preparation for
differentiation into the final
cell cell product this differentiation
process
occurs in suspension bioreactors and
this is where we see the rotator being
integrated into our process
allowing us to have a closed processed
media exchange and harvest
and also efficient and streamlined
processing to
process our aggregates and remove any
non-aggregate debris
after this part of the process we then
move to crowd preservation and post dog
culture
finishes out the production of our cell
therapy product
so in order to integrate the rotate into
our process
we first had to perform some initial
testing
with our aggregates just to see what
parameters would be good to maintain
accurate morphology integrity and
viability as they were processed
and the way we did this was with just a
very basic
initial testing setup using a couple of
bottle assemblies i'm going to walk you
through here
and this allowed us to see what flow
rates and what centrifuge speeds
were best suited for maintaining
aggregate morphology integrity and
viability
so first we drew aggregate cells in
through an input bottle
this would be representative of our
suspension buyer reactor
the cells were drawn into the rotia
counterflow centrifugation cone
and we tried to form beds at various
flow rates and centrifuge speeds
the spent media from the input i sent to
the waste
along with any non-aggregate cell debris
that was removed from the fluidized bed
by the rotam
the aggregates still in this counterflow
centrifugation cone were then washed
with fresh medium and finally the
processed and concentrated aggregates
were sent from the rotate to a harvest
bottle
where we could then confirm that the
aggregates were
still viable and still intact and this
setup allowed us
to narrow down the range of flow rates
and century speeds that best maintain
our accurate prospect properties that we
were looking for
so like i mentioned there were two
process parameters that we were
primarily interested
in optimizing one is the pump flow rate
and the reason we're interested in this
parameter is because if it's too low
we have a slow processing time with the
rotation but there may be some
improved aggregate retention conversely
if
pump flow rate is too high we get faster
processing
but we might have lower viability of
retention of our aggregates
on the flip side when we're optimizing
centrifuge feed
if the centrifuge speed is too low you
won't retain any of your aggregates
they'll be alluded directly to the waste
conversely there if your centrifuge
speed is too high
you're going to have low aggregate
viability and you might also retain some
of the debris that you don't want in
your final product
so these were the two primary parameters
that we were interested in optimizing
using the test setup that we just saw
it is worth mentioning there are several
other parameters that may affect the
process inputs or outputs
however these were assumed constant for
testing for practical reasons
some of these include the media density
and viscosity the density of the
aggregates themselves
the diameter of the aggregates and the
number of wash steps performed by the
rotate during our process
so one of the other things that we're
evaluating during these initial tests
was we wanted to make sure that our
process
actually formed a fluidized bed in the
counterflow centrifugation cone
and this is important because the
fluidized bed maintains
the integrity of the aggregates and also
ensures that they are correctly
retained and sent to the harvest as
opposed to being sent to the waste
and as you can see on the picture on the
left there we were able to successfully
form
a nice looking fluidized bed in the
counter flow centrifuge cone
we're also interested in evaluating the
viability of the aggregates after
processing
and this could be visually seen by any
turbidity
in the counterflow centrifuge cone
during processing
and also a post post-process we would
look at the aggregates under
a light microscope as seen in the middle
picture there
and confirmed that the aggregates were
intact and then
using software to make sure that our
diameter after processing
is comparable to the diameter before
processing we would also look at the
viability before and after processing
as seen on the graph on the far right
pretest we would see aggregate viability
in the high 90
post test we would also see comparable
viability after rotea processing
another thing we're interested in for
our production process
is processing the aggregates over
multiple days or multiple media
exchanges
and this is because as emily mentioned
our production process takes several
days
so we want to be able to use the rotia
for multiple days if possible
without any negative effects on our
aggregates and
so during our testing we processed the
accurates for multiple successive
days in a row and observed a minimum
loss
in viability as seen on the graph on the
left here over three days
we would process the aggregates once
each day
with a divide of victim retail and we
would see minimum change
in viability after each processing at
only about three percent loss in
viability
after each test we also looked at
diameter after multiple successive
processing days
and once again saw a minimal change in
aggregate diameter as seen on the graph
on the right
in fact on day two we actually saw a
slight not statistically sniffing about
a slight increase
in aggregate diameter suggesting that
we're in fact removing
some of the non non-aggregate debris
that would have small diameters that's a
good thing we wanted to see
that debris could send to the waste
instead of the harvest
so now that we've established the uh
approximate initial conditions that we
want to see
integrated into our production process
we can also look into possible future
applications
of the rotate to our cell therapy
production process
so this is our overview of our
production process
expansion differentiation preservation
of postdoc culture
we're currently looking in the middle
there to integrating the rotate to our
aggregation differentiation steps
however in the future we might be able
to look to integrating the rotate into
our expansion
steps where the rotation might have a
role in stem cell expansion
cell passaging it might also be useful
for our crowd preservation and post-spot
culture steps
specifically for the preservation
harvest and during our post-thought
culture
and with that some concluding remarks
viacite
is developing some stem cell derived
therapies to functionally cure type 1
diabetes
and in order to meet this ambitious goal
we need an ambitious scale of effort
to support our predicted cell therapy
demand the rotia
provides a scalable technology that can
support closed and efficient processing
or stem cell aggregate therapy and our
preliminary results
show high aggregate viability and normal
morphology over consecutive processing
days
thank you for your attention
thank you pram emily and eric for your
informative
presentations we would now like to start
the live q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do not hesitate to do so now
and your preferred language just click
on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and now
let's get started with the questions for
buyer site
our first question is how can you
process
larger volumes of around 10 liters with
the rotia
that is a good question so as you scale
and batch volume
uh your cell product volume increases as
well
since the maximum hold volume of the
rotate counterflow centrifugation
10 milliliters of fluidized bed the path
forward would be to process the
bioreactor solution in matches
each one comprised of a maximum volume
of maximum
aggregate volume of 10 milliliters and
this can occur multiple times depending
on your load size
and additionally the high flow kit
allows for improved flow rates to
support
faster processing of these larger
batches
why did biocite choose a suspension
culture method
in general what are the overall benefits
you see in suspension culture
versus 2d adherent methods for stem cell
research
well perhaps emily could address this
yeah um so the advantage of suspension
culture over
2d adherent methods for stem cell
production becomes
really apparent as the stem cell
expansion and differentiation process
is scaled compared to the adherent
methods
some fall production processes utilizing
suspension culture combine
improved cell processing characteristics
such as
unlimited capacity for growth so no
surface area limitations
and then at a lower aseptic risk with
lower production costs so
reduced equipment footprint and labor
requirements
thank you emily our next question what
led to bioscience decision
in selecting the rotia for bioreactor
processing
um yeah so in addition to its ability to
maintain
aggregate viability integrity and
morphology um the rattaya's counterflow
centrifugation technology is scalable
making it as suitable
as making it suitable for biosite
process as we
scale up production additionally the
rotia also
matches our requirement for repeated
batch
bioreactor media exchange versus
typical perfusion based processes on the
market
and now this question is for eric what
are the greatest challenges to rotia
optimization for cell aggregate
processing
good question the stem cell aggregates
that we work with they require
gentle handling because they can be
quite fragile
it's necessary to maintain accurate
integrity during the processing
because this is a critical part of their
functionality in the final product
so modifying the rotea process
parameters to adequately collect
wash refeed the aggregates from
bioreactors it took some fine tuning to
do
but assistance from thermo fisher and
working through
the through the parameters to optimize
the shear forces
was was an interesting process however
we have achieved successful cultures
utilizing this system
and eric can you further detail what
other processes
the rotia could add value in
sure so as we discussed in the
presentation uh biosite has adapted the
rotate to our stem cell aggregate
differentiation process
however we see a multiple multitude of
other areas where the retail could offer
support
one of those includes the final harvest
for crop preservation
when we generate our drug substance we
require an intermediate freezing step
for long-term storage and the rotia
could benefit this process by
concentrating
washing and collecting the final product
in crime preservation media
thank you it looks like we have one
final question for biocite
when adapting your feeding and
harvesting process to the rotia
did you run into issues if the aggregate
solution is not uniform
for example do you observe heterogeneous
mix of smaller to larger aggregates
that is a great question because our
aggregates
do tend to range inside size we commonly
see aggregate solutions
that have sent several standard
deviations worth of size approximately
50
there but since the aggregates are so
much larger than the single cells we
want to remove from the solution
we haven't had a whole lot of issues
separating the two
all right thank you emily and eric so
now that we
have finished all the questions that
we've consolidated for via site
we really thank both emily and eric for
spending the time
to deliver this webinar and for
evaluating the rotia system it looks
like they had really good
results and application data using a
rotia to process pluripotent stem cells
uh in our next session we still have
some time i would like to call upon dr
pram kumar
and our panel of technical specialists
from thermal fisher
korea japan and taiwan offices
to address the broader questions around
rotia or any questions related
to cell and gene therapy manufacturing
so feel free to continue to type your
questions in your preferred language
we have another number of questions
coming in
and the q a box is located on the far
left of your screen
okay so on our panel we have uh
drag kuma we have uh
ogita's son from japan we have jasmine
from taiwan
and we have doyang kim from
korea so let me start with the first
question
for friends
what are the steps planned to make it
suitable
what are the steps planned to make the
rotia suitable for use
in later phase and commercial processes
okay um great question um so cts rotier
system
um is designed for clinical and
commercial
cell therapy manufacturing um and the
single use kits
are cgmp grade and both the instrument
and the kits are manufactured under
iso one three four eight five um again
the single use kits are qc tested
individually and uh
further the kits are gamma sterilized
and packed individually
um and rotia's intended uses for
research
uh use or manufacturing of cell and gene
therapy or tissue-based products
and rotia software has operator and
administrator modes for manufacturing
um and to further that uh rotia is 21
cfr part 11 compliance software solution
uh will also be available um in q3 of
this year
all right thank you very much pram and
now let's move on to the second
question which is uh i think what the
the audience might want to learn more
about
how does the cts wrote here compared to
kunimax prodigy from miltoni
okay so this is again a very good
question
um rotia is very very different
from the miltonis prodigy on many fronts
again rotia is an open platform that
allows you to use
any reagents from any suppliers and most
importantly it's a modular system
um so rotia combined with an offline
incubator
would not be tied down over several days
or weeks of
culture um so this is unlike uh the
clini max prodigy
which does not have an integrated
incubator um which makes the scale up of
the manufacturing seamless
and grants the user more flexibility to
connect routier
uh to any culture bags um single-use
vessels or bioreactors
of or downstream of the forces
okay thank you prem and now i'd like to
direct you to some questions that came
in from lisa
i think she has three two questions
uh the first uh can this system be
thought
of as a mini bioreactor of momentum
okay um so roti is not a mini bioreactor
or a fermenter
roti is basically a cell processing
device
um right so it's specifically intended
as i mentioned for cell and gene therapy
manufacturing
um and then there is no temperature
control system
in wrote here for you to control your
cell culture expansion so it's just a
self-processing device
it's a counter flow centrifugation
system where you can process yourself
uh upstream or downstream into your
bioreactor or cell factories
but again you cannot use root here for
expanding any
cells hope that's clear
okay thank you and another question from
lisa
is
can this system be used to separate
uh two or more cells i presume she's
asking about
two or more cell populations with
similar physical
properties such as cell density
uh cell size or diameter
okay so this is a very important
question so as i mentioned um
rotia is a counter flow centrifugation
and because of that
unique technology that you can separate
cells based on sites
so any cells um i mean any cell
population with a three micron
size difference we could use rotia to
separate
say for example lymphocytes are
typically around
six to eight microns and monocytes are
around 10 to 12 microns
in size so there's a minimum of three
micron size that is required for us to
separate out
lymphocytes and monocyte population and
similarly it goes like when you want to
separate
live cells and dead cells um dead cells
are usually smaller in size compared to
the life cells
so you can wash away the dead cells
using the counter flow centrifugation
process
and you can have a very high viable cell
in there um
and again cell density plays a major
role
in the separation so higher the cell
density the separation efficiency might
be
um might be it might be different
compared to a low flow cell density
buffer
so those are the two key parameters that
is required for you to do a cell
separation
okay thank you pram i hope that
addresses some of lisa's questions
and now i'm moving on to some questions
that were uh
written in other languages so first we
have a question
coming in from taiwan so i'll invite
jasmine to read the question and if you
could do a very quick translation in
english that would help the audience
okay so
the question is about how involved is
the support
of for developing a process can you help
design the program
used for ourselves um the answer is yes
but since the question is written in
chinese i will
um
yeah okay uh thank you
thank you very much uh jasmine uh do you
wanna give a very quick short statement
and respond to that question in english
i think do we offer development process
support yeah
sure um so i repeat the question uh
whether
uh the mobile pressure support the
customer for the for developing the
process
and designing a program for their sales
thermostation scientific is in fact
invested in the success of
uh its repair customer and provides
support throughout the
instrument buying experience um a custom
protocol
is developed for each rotia system demo
in order to stop a customer application
a live cell demo is performed with the
rotia system for the customer's
evaluation
some official scientific includes
initial equipment
and software training by our trained
field application scientists both sales
and fas and tech support teams were also
available for further protocol
development assistance
i hope it addressed the question thanks
all right thank you very much jasmine
now quickly moving on
we have a question in korean
douyan would you like to read that out
and also give a very short
response in english as well thank you
yeah okay well let me see
can the rotator system be connected to
multi-layer flask
cell what sell as sell factories or
sales tax
answer is yes rota is extend extremely
flexible
rota has been connected to incubators by
reactors and cell factories
and directs g-rex and so on in order to
connect you to cell factories pvc2
c-flex tubing
adapters will be required if you are
interested in learning more about
the technical details making close
connection to different
foreign
foreign
all right thank you uh and now moving on
to a question by uh yamamoto
would you like to take this question
okay uh can you hear me
yes um thank you um i'm going to firstly
translate the
question in japanese in english
so the question is what is the maximum
number of cells
that can be processed you know one time
and how long would it take so
i'm going to firstly uh answer in
japanese
foreign i finished the answering in
japanese
so i'd like to hand it over to jack
quinton
okay uh thank you uh noble
so uh we have another question from
um from takeda asking is
so noble you could answer this as well
have you used inline filter
in cluster wash concentrate experiment
i see inline filter
[Music]
okay
sure would you like to take that
question in english as well
if it's a quick response yeah
impossible could you answer the question
if you have an answer
sure so the question in english is have
you used inline filter
and cluster wash concentrate experiments
i mean we can say that we it's possible
to use inline filters
you could simply well filter if it's pvc
material to the pvc rotier kit
and it's again the rotator is very
flexible
uh we don't see any issues at attaching
an inline filter
i hope that addresses the questions okay
so thank you very much uh uh and now we
have a final
question uh do you have any plans to
expand the application of rotia to
target more clinical spaces
perhaps prem would you like to take this
question
okay yeah sure yeah that's a good
question uh but
we are not going to expand it towards uh
the clinical processing um
because um roti is intended only for
cell and gene therapy manufacturing and
rotia is not
uh afresis processing medical device
meaning that you cannot use rhodia to
perform
an apheresis to basically
take out from the patient sample by
connecting rotia to the patient uh
uh by taking out the atherosis once you
have used a
pro afresis processing machine to uh
take out a leukopak or an aphrosis
product
you can again use rotia to basically
process those
apheresis material to separate out the
pvmcs
and then further separate the
lymphocytes and monocytes
for for your cell therapy manufacturing
hope that answers your question
all right thank you very much fran i
think we have
addressed all the questions in the chat
box i would like to thank the audience
for
uh you know putting through such
interesting questions
so i hope that today's session has been
um you know you've learned a lot from
today's session and again i would like
to
thank our three speakers uh for their
time
so in closing this website of our
session would be like we would like to
thank viacite
emily and eric for sharing their
experiences that's very valuable to the
field
i would like to thank prem and our
technical specialist from thermal fishes
regional offices
and a big thank you for to you all for
joining us today and submitting
interesting questions
so if you have any more questions feel
free to uh
you know send us an email um and we will
also like to thank
latroots for underwriting today's
educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
those who have missed it
and lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
events